good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday also
known as hump day and i'm very excited
because the girl sitting next to me is
so beautiful i might hump her welcome
back to the show tasha
you've become like madonna you're just
like a one a tasha i was looking at your
instagram this morning and yeah
instagram is just tasha yeah that's so
cool i mean to be honest with you i love
it that way yeah i really don't
fun fact about me
last name has changed um right before
and it almost did again so at this point
we're just dropping it off got it is
adam's your
birth name my maiden maiden that's the
right word
yeah well welcome back to the show i
love having you here you are a hard
woman to book you're traveling you're
here you're there you're a star you're
hosting the bachelor the bachelorette
hello is tasha welcome back to new york
first of all
i love it here number one it's warmer
today yes
it's been
the rest of the week which i have a bone
to pick with new york you all know that
mother nature um but i'm so happy i'm
like in this city i love it i feel more
new york like a city girl yeah orange
county and this is your permanent
residence right i mean i still have a
place in orange county oh you do yeah
and you travel a lot yeah your family's
there yeah like i actually booked a
flight for tomorrow so oh no
i need sun 100 100 percent so what's it
like living in new york um not a lot of
people who come off the bachelor live in
new york a lot of people moving to l.a
no
i feel like
i was one of the first yeah okay
now there's about 35 people and i'm just
like i actually
tried to do something different
now it's like this is the main hub for
all bachelors you're not like other
girls no i mean you know what now i just
have to move to london totally well the
thing is is i have to be totally honest
the last season of the bachelor i ever
watched was your season well you slashed
claire um and i'm so excited you're here
because we have this running joke at the
toast that like i need to tell you about
so when we used to recap your season for
some reason we we back onto like not
really a busy street but there's a
street behind us and for some reason
like whenever we would talk about you
like these trucks would would honk their
horns so loud and it's like annoying for
us because when you try to record audio
you want premium silence and they're
always being so loud so we used to call
them the truckers for t-shirts because
they were here supporting you and every
time we would say the word tasha i swear
to god the truck would show up yes so
the truckers for tasha i hope they show
up today but i want to let you know like
you have the truckers of america behind
you
it's so funny though because like that
started appearing on my instagram and
i'm like i don't know what that means
but like yeah people go chuggers for
tasha like and they'll say like all the
time and i was like i mean like it's
because i wear trucker hats sometimes
like
confused time i'm so maybe i need to
at
i'm
date a trucker like i didn't know what
they were trying to say no literally the
truckers for t-shirt they are like a
fierce group wow well thank you trackers
for tasia thank you
appreciate it yeah the truckers i
actually pay all of them to do that
so i believe it yeah um okay so let's
catch up a little bit you're gonna dive
into the fast five it's also wednesday
so we're gonna get advice okay we've got
some interesting submissions today and i
would love to get your take on that lord
but before we catch up on that like
how's single life how's taisha doing
tasha is actually doing really well
which
i'm not gonna lie it was a little rocky
of course for a little bit breakups are
hard very hard um but also at the same
time i really think that my trip to
london was kind of like the refresh the
rebirth the like
new rejuvenation yes it's exactly what i
needed and
it's been phenomenal ever since it's
good yeah it's kind of just like you
needed to just do something on your own
and that's what exactly i needed to do
um
and i just walked around everyone's like
what did you do there like did you have
an agenda i'm like right i actually went
with no agenda and like that was the
agenda yeah um and
i just learned so much about myself
although
it is a little odd constantly going to
like happy hour by yourself
it gets a little sad yeah just a little
bit so
um i did start to like make friends and
whatnot but um i'm happy to be back in
the city do you prefer traveling by
yourself or with like friends
um
i don't think i've ever traveled by
myself that wasn't like work related
it's actually really fun to travel by
yourself i can imagine because like you
don't have to worry about like everybody
else but also at the same time
um
you can like stay longer you can do this
do that i don't know you can meet
whoever and you don't feel like oh great
they want to go home and i'm like down
and talk to you i don't know it's
actually really nice you know i imagine
that it is but you have to have like a
lot of um confidence yes and no well
yeah you definitely kind of feel like a
fish out of water like everyone's
watching me right now especially in the
new country but no one actually cares
about you that is the most important
thing you've ever said no one actually
cares and i think that like as you grow
up it's like a lesson you think like
everyone is looking at you all the time
if you embarrass yourself like
everyone's thinking about it yeah and
once you come to learn that literally
nobody cares about you it is so well
you're like a famous person so like some
people do care about you but like
just like socially when you come to
realize that like there's so much
freedom with that lesson like no one's
thinking about you it's so true and you
know what new york actually kind of
warmed me up to that first because i
started doing like this thing like where
i take myself out dinner every sunday
like i actually love it i go to dinner
this is odd but like i don't know if
you've ever gone to go get like a foot
rub it's like four dollars like an hour
it's the best like literally so i'm more
of a better girly but yeah oh okay
so i love to go get like at least a
glass or two of rose go get a foot rub
it's like literally the best thing
that's ever happened my best friend now
doesn't she's like this is probably the
best advice you could have ever given me
um but yeah i do that and
i was talking about foot rubs for a
second
i was
get to go to dinner and date yourself
for a little bit i couldn't agree more i
also feel like coming off the heels of
your breakup you were so booked and busy
always work wise so you like i actually
feel like that's a blessing in disguise
you don't really have time to like sit
in your own self-pity and just be sad
yeah you have to catch those checks
absolutely which is the best i mean like
i'm not i'm not saying no to it right
right keep it coming you just got so
free let's take on more work almost like
a little too free though yes but at the
same time i don't know i really needed
that moment to myself and i still have
it right now which is nice it comes in
spurts right now but i think i've kind
of designed my life
um to be that way this year yeah just to
like really kind of be in the city i
also you've just like you've had such a
uh
jam-packed career since the bachelor i
always forget
that you also hosted like a bunch of
seasons yeah it's kind of odd right what
was that like going from a contestant to
a lead to a host which i think like is
the dream i mean
it's kind of amazing like i still pinch
myself over it because i i don't think i
ever realized exactly what was going on
it was crazy because it's just like okay
yeah okay yeah like and you you say yes
to everything exactly and it's basically
your family you've done it time and time
i've been with them for like what four
years now right so it you kind of didn't
think twice but at the same time
i like cannot even believe like
do you remember me on cold season i
don't know if you do but like honestly
yes i was the quietest shyest like
little
i don't even know what i just probably
bought my eyelashes right but then you
really came in into your own paradise
okay i loved paradise though and you
were like
everything
everything like i just
and i don't even watch a bachelor
anymore so like my frame of reference
from like bachelor history yeah is
really the last couple of years that you
were on and you were just a star i feel
like you never really shied away from
being yourself you always pulled out the
looks and i i have so many questions
about paradise because i can't imagine
like anything worse than getting ready
in the heat there's no air conditioning
like the hair the sweaty makeup like
for me personally it's like just a big
sweater it is my worst nightmare and you
might as well have been in antarctica
you just showed up everywhere like
snatch to the gods listen okay i feel
bad for you for number one but this is
the thing i love the heat i don't sweat
are you from oc no i like live for it
like so it was like
the perfect situation for me to even
have my season in palm springs but it
was 122 degrees that would have been my
worst nightmare
the men looked like they had like just
showered and i was just like why are you
guys hot and yeah sweating through their
shirts i loved it so i don't know
paradise is like like my element i'm
also half mexican so it's like right
it's like home i get it i get it well
you did it flawlessly well thank you i
mean
sort of well i mean i'm sure there's a
lot margarita helps
but in terms of getting selected to be a
host i feel like
there's so many contestants that come
out of the show people love them they
get tons of different jobs opportunities
but to be selected by bachelor nation
for that job with caitlyn obviously yeah
what does that feel like did you feel
like you were just better than everyone
because i would have felt that oh my god
no i was like are you sure like you're
sweet is it me like but also it's very
nerve-wracking because you feel like you
have to like
uphold a lot like you have to be on a
certain level and you're like
i'm still you're like the same i was a
contestant right now it's a house and
like you don't want to like try to make
people feel like i'm inferior i don't
know just it's a different dynamic but
also at the same time like it really did
build me up and i also feel like i was
meant to be in that you were you were
killer i i feel like that's like what i
want to do for my life it's like
perfect place to start i'm really happy
good and i'm thankful but like also like
damn straight yeah no you killed it
thank you and though in terms of getting
back out there dating wise yeah assuming
i know the answer to this question but
would you ever date bachelor nation
absolutely not that's what i figured i
think that's the sentiment from a lot of
people yeah who go on the show and it
like doesn't work out well the reason
why though too is just like
it's really hard having a public
relationship and i don't like
i don't even imagine like what i can't
even imagine what a celebrity feels like
but for me for bachelor like those fans
are such diehards and they feel like
they
have to be in on everything there's an
entitlement absolutely but even like you
can say like oh we're just in a funk
today we're just not doing well like
they will completely come up with an
entire different scenario and you're
like wait i just actually told you what
the problem was right and now you're
running with this tangent and it's like
this whole thing you have to like fight
and it actually starts [ __ ] in your
relationship of course and i'm just like
do you want us to freak out or do you
not want us to work out me and jackie
always say normalize looking miserable
in relationships because a lot of times
we'll get paparazzi pictures yeah it'll
turn into a whole story like trouble in
paradise right like we're human beings
like if i was photographed with ben like
people would think we're getting
divorced every single day like i'm just
a miserable person like that's just like
what i look like normalizing being
miserable yeah because it's just a part
of life not every part of a relationship
is going to be like hehehe the best ever
so true
and like that's also weird if it is
always like that a hundred percent you
know what i mean
like it's not always like you know roses
in your relationship like what's wrong
with you it's so true so i just love
seeing you in the season of your life
and what's the expertisa oh god i mean
hopefully more hosting opportunities i
feel like that's like really where i'm
trying to like hone in right now well
you're always welcome here at the
morning oh well thank you
honestly it's the cutest that ever so
like i feel right
but um other than that like right now
i'm really just trying to come into like
the world of me being like a single
woman that can actually provide for
herself and like there's no better feel
confident no it it's really not and it's
like confident in herself i have a lot
to offer
girl you have a lot to offer thank you
you always have it takes a lot to like
actually like feel that way though i
know i know and you know the last time
you were on the show i think it was
before you were the lead i think it was
right after paradise you were still
living in oc yeah and you were still
this just like wonderfully charismatic
positive person like you have this
almost toxic positivity about you like
you are so smiley all the time like
you're so nice you're so lovely and it's
nice to see that like after all you know
the opportunities and where you've come
from you're really still the same [ __ ]
oh thank you and i mean that in a
positive way also another thing we say
here at the morning toast normally
saying the word [ __ ] like
it's a positive word it's definitely a
high used word in my vocabulary no same
and like everyone's like [ __ ] it's no
it's no it's like a dear man i was just
saying it's endearing yeah this is me my
best friend called each other all day
every day
in a while i didn't want to like make
you feel bad no no
i would be offended if you didn't call
me a [ __ ] okay
[Laughter]
but like also my family and my best
friend keep me very humble too so it's
also really nice to like
have that very like
solid foundation has it been hard to
live further away from them like harder
than you expected i mean honestly i'm
like i'm never coming home they're like
you haven't been home forever like can
you please come out like no no like i'm
actually not you're living your best
life i love being here but i've also
lived at home my entire life right and
so i think my parents are finally to the
fact like you've been home for every
holiday like you don't have to come home
right like go do your thing are you on
any dating apps no are you against it
yes for what particular reason just
because like i'm a hopeless romantic and
i really feel like i'll just like run
into like my man like instead of the
eiffel tower oh god please yeah just
like across like this like the crosswalk
and you just like see him he like winks
at you and it's just like this whole
romantic freaking thing yeah like i
really thought i was gonna fall in love
in london yeah i know i could have
totally seen that for you like a london
businessman yeah because like there was
this guy that i don't know if you saw my
stories but i was actually like in my
hotel room and i was dancing around and
like my eyes
yeah and there was a guy that was like
actually looking at me like how romantic
could that been like
he was actually really cute and he fell
in love normal not a cereal but also
like
i definitely got a better look at him i
was like absolutely not
so where was he like across the street
so the buildings are very close like
here in new york right and he like my
windows here his work building
office cubicle is right there
didn't really realize that they were
like that close and i guess it was a
work day i was on vacation and um
literally turned around he's giggling
straight up looking at me and i'm just
like oh i just like grabbed everything i
had like
okay i have to say like it does sound
like a meat cube but it also sounds like
a peeping tom no wait yes it could have
been really it could be like it's funny
how you could put a spit on something
like it's really cute but also like
really scary i didn't even think about
like i could have gotten that could have
been a serial killer yeah no or like he
would like take pictures of you and then
become obsessed with you and like start
uh like a wall in his house with
pictures of you oh
my we now i'm scared to travel by myself
that wasn't the point of what i was
trying to say
dang it it just goes to say you know
be careful perspective is everything
yeah absolutely i'm just gonna like live
in my fantasy that like and you know
what i'm sorry i didn't mean to burst
your love bubble you know what i'm toxic
and i'm sorry and i apologize we gotta
think about these things we're gonna
dive into the fast five and i wanna know
like are you a pop culture girl because
you it's it's a weird place to be in
when like you're you're a fan of pop
culture but then you also become a part
of it yeah what is that like i am and
i'm not like everyone expects you to
kind of like be binging all these tv
shows right like i think part of the
reason i took a step back from bachelor
nation
there's a multitude of things but also
like i can't really like give a lot of
input on it because i kind of stopped
watching the shows of course once you
see all the sauces
well yeah but like it was just a lot for
a minute i just needed to breathe so
even with like i watch little housewives
and whatnot right um i watch obviously
keeping up of course what did you think
of the first episode okay
i'm actually obsessed with it so good
but also i feel like they kind of do
like a little like bachelor twist
because like they don't go in like their
little
interview rooms anymore
like it's like kim like like all the
side of the set yeah it's giving
documentary i kind of love it me too
it's very real right yeah
but okay did you like the vibe of it i
love i loved every every moment freaking
second of it i thought it was much
better than the e-show in the sense that
esho had so much filler yes so much
idiotic pranks and and you know what i
don't not everything is going to be high
drama all the time but i really am
interested to see how they live day to
day like what do you eat for lunch i
thought like what they were eating at
the barbecue was so interesting no it
wasn't like i love how close i was like
i kind of forgot what it feels like to
have the cameras and kim's like just
pretend they're not there like right
talking about the cameras is normal it
was so cool i completely agree i don't
know i feel like very close to them i
don't know why and chloe just looks so
bomb no i know i feel very close to them
too in like a delusional way no it's
yeah i know you do
you love them when they get together i'm
like
where why the [ __ ] and i'm dead serious
like how was i not invited
like i feel actual fomo for people who
have no idea who i am it's rude honestly
god i want to meet him i know i have met
her you have okay well i'll tell you
this i was at the beverly hills hotel
once having dinner and she looked back
at me like i think she looked and then
she like looked back again well you know
she watches the bachelor
well one time she was actually looking
at her phone there was a picture from
the paparazzi like from right behind it
was my face on her phone like she was
reading an article
and yeah i kind of freaked out semi wait
that's the craziest thing ever i know
what was the article about it was back
when it was like a colton season it was
like me hannah and cassie i think oh my
god yeah i know i kind of felt i don't
know it was like very cool no that's
literally like put that on my tombstone
that's cool to say no like she knows my
face yeah of course
she watches she totally knows who you
are i feel like you can meet her soon
okay so i can like i want to be honest
gives campaign well you know we have it
on you know decent authority that kylie
actually listens to the podcast really
yeah um so if you not every day
but
feel free to speak into the camera
directly kylie
well you're iconic and also
i want some lip kits yeah yeah by the
way uh same yeah let's get those
okay so tasia's going to join me for the
past five and dear toasters so without
further ado i think it's time to dive
into the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
honey thanks to honey manually searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds to your
cart so how it works is imagine you're
shopping
at one of your favorite websites for me
i buy electronics i buy food i buy
clothing makeup all with honey and when
you check out the honey button drops
down and all you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons and if it
finds a working one it'll watch you'll
watch the price drop i just got a new
computer first thing i did download
honey they even offer cashback at
thousands of stores so it's basically
like earning cash rewards for just
shopping if you don't already have honey
you are straight up missing out on
savings so by getting it you're doing
yourself a solid and we never recommend
something we don't use so you can get
honey for free at joinhoney.com
toast that's join honey.com toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by fastgrowingtreats.com
spring and summer are the seasons for
finally getting outdoors and for
entertaining pool parties barbecues etc
but if your yard looks like a plant
cemetery then you're not going to enjoy
it as much get your place looking great
like a resort with easy fast growing
trees when it comes to caring for your
plants know how matters and that's why
fastgrowingtree.com
expert curates thousands of plant
varieties that will thrive in your
specific climate location and needs
there's no waiting in lines no messy
cars from hauling plants all over town
because you order online or over the
phone and your plants are shipped
straight to your door in one to two days
plus they're growing
and care advice is available 24 7.
whether you're looking for increased
privacy shade or adding some natural
beauty to your yard fast growing trees
have the perfect plants and the
expertise to help you find them even if
you never had a green thumb like myself
they'll make you feel like you do and a
million home gardeners have already seen
what fastgrowingtrees.com
can do for them as you guys know we once
had a plant and it died because we are
not plant girlies mick plant rest in
peace you will be missed thank you for
all you did here at the morning toast
but fast growing trees having like a
whole hotline for advice if you're not a
plant girly is really really helpful and
with their 30 day alive and thrive
guarantee you can trust everything will
be healthy for years to come go to
fastgrowingtrees.com toast right now and
you'll get 15 off your entire order
that's 15 off at fast growing trees
toast fastgrowingtrees.com
oh what was that toast
all right tasha are you ready i am ready
so i know you said you watch housewives
you don't watch potomac which is just a
huge flaw in you like you need to watch
especially when you've confided in me
before the show that you're watching
orange county
and i know you're from there listen how
can you not watch it though like they're
literally in my backyard oh how can i
not watch it uh easily yeah okay yeah
it's really it's it's bad it's going
downhill it's real the music video i
mean okay wait i don't even want to talk
about it because like honestly i'm the
second hand embarrassment is real it's
the point where i was watching i was
like absolutely not yes my computer
i was gone you see them around town when
you're in a scene um
yes and no i've seen like emily and gina
and i like them actually yeah and gina
they're kind of fun but i haven't like
really interacted with them now would
you ever be a housewife
no you could say no but like
it depends which one and where the
franchise is like right now oc's in a
lull so you might want to be associated
i want to be like beverly hills
housewife girl me too i mean come on who
doesn't well there's some big news
coming out of potomac and i'll explain
to you why it's important okay so ashley
darby has announced a separation from
her husband michael no one is the root
cause she says so the real housewives of
potomac star told bravo's daily dish on
tuesday she said almost eight years ago
when michael and i said i do we
anticipated sharing every single day
together from that moment forward
unfortunately that is not our current
reality we have decided to separate we
are aware that there will be many
viewers speculating as to why we have
made this decision people will be quick
to assume that the causes were too much
intrusion by reality tv
into the most personal parts of our
lives age gap issues cultural problems
or child rearing differences pieces of
all these may have affected our pure
love for each other but no one reason is
the root cause for a mutual decision to
go our separate ways we are now both at
very different stages in our lives and
we have different goals for the future
yada yada so let me tell you why this is
like please explain okay so ashley came
on the scene husband michael much older
than her okay i'm just like a weird guy
but you know what like she stood by him
and it was actually admirable after all
they'd been through she like ride or
died for this man even after he was
accused of like horrific things she was
actually it was crazy so he was accused
of sexual assault
to multiple staff on the production team
wait what yeah like grabbing guys asses
and there have long been rumors of him
being gay and you know
eventually the charges got dropped but
there was like weird footage yeah it was
like a crazy couple seasons of potomac
and it was all really about michael he
cheated on her with a stripper while she
was pregnant
really like not a good guy but through
and through with every allegation she
was a really good housewife in the sense
that she shared everything okay she had
really uncomfortable conversations on tv
she found out about the stripper on tv
and she handled it like a champ wow but
through and through
she never left his side and they kept
having more babies and so i believe i
think she just gave birth to her third
or she's pregnant with her third
whatever something about the third baby
and now fans are like why now and it
really seemed to me like she wanted to
have kids yeah and as many as she could
and then she bounced and then she was
like she got her dream she got what she
wanted what she wanted and you know what
i think ashley darby is an amazing
housewife and i really like her and even
though i don't agree with a lot of the
time she defended michael i'm kind of
happy for her like she got her kids yeah
and now she can bounce
i mean
i feel bad for her like i know it was
really tough how do you stand by i mean
you know every relationship is different
and you know you always like have your
own opinions and you never know what to
really never know what it's like to
actually be in that relationship so but
like power to her for like
i guess sticking in it as long as she
possibly could but i'm happy that she's
now getting out of it i agree with you i
know and they discussed last season as
she didn't have a prenup he has a lot of
money
um so we love that for her she's taking
half and her kids okay well she got what
she wanted i know and i feel like now
we're gonna see her in the next couple
seasons totally different light i know
and like she's gonna be iconic like
she's gonna be in she's gonna be like
you like independent and i'm telling you
like i just see
i see she fun like she's everything she
like loves to drink she like was always
drinking a corona even she's just cute
she's also like a pot stir bone carrying
a housewife
there always has to be a little bit of
that you can't not be a house i would
not have that but i think and she's
never been like afraid of a fight i
think that like she is going to enter
like the next couple years as like one
of the greatest housewives of all time
without michael the michael stuff was
always bringing her down like no one
could really take her seriously
interesting yeah okay well then this is
actually really good news i'm actually
really excited to see this maybe i'll
tune in you i can't believe you don't
watch potomac
it is the most underrated franchise i
think it's okay up there with beverly
hills
wait
what and people don't give it enough i
thought jersey was up there with
jersey's also really good this season
but potomac is just this underrated
franchise because i think a lot of
people haven't heard of potomac
geographically yeah it's a newer
franchise but i'm telling you like we
just came off some of the great like i
can't believe you don't know about
monique versus candace like no it is no
i don't it's so good okay how many
seasons are there not that many i think
maybe they just wrapped their sixth and
is it necessary to binge the entire
thing or can i like
hop in you're gonna want to okay it's
that good and you know jesus me and
jackie both binged it like two years ago
so we we haven't even been watching from
the beginning i'm just it's so enjoyable
and they have some characters especially
in the beginning like katie ross who i
hear is coming back like my gosh it's so
good and it makes me annoyed that like
it's not as
popular as other franchises like it was
the same kind of story as real house as
of dallas which i'm not sure you watched
no it was cancelled and you know what
like it wasn't that great yeah but they
launch at the same time and like
housewives fans have been watching for
so long i think they're very skeptical
of new franchises i'm just gonna say i
feel like they have like their shows
that they stick to and like that's it
and there's like a hierarchy yeah you
know yes but potomac is that [ __ ] i'm
telling you really i will preach the
gospel of potomac to anyone i mean if
you said it's all the way up with
beverly hills okay fine yeah
when people ask me my top two franchises
i'll usually say potomac and beverly
hills and i'll only not say jersey
because jersey this season is amazing
yeah but not every season is as good
right you know but they're always they
always keep it
good they're never entered it's always
juicy and there's always a lot of family
drama like we get it they've never
gotten it to a place of like ocean or
new york which right now is both
experiencing some just really horrendous
content
really bad what do you think about the
news that real housewives of new york is
now being split into two shows did you
hear about that yeah but i i'm excited
for like the ogs to come by me too but
like this whole new spin on it it's a
little confusing to me like is julia fox
like really
and if so like i don't think that's a
show i'm interested in watching i don't
think that's the show i'm interested in
watching either which is so weird to me
because i feel like
yeah but you know what people always say
this like people are always so pissed
for like a certain bachelor bachelorette
and guess what your ass is watching it
every single week and here you are
commenting and like so obsessed and
you're in love and you're in bed ready
to watch it no you are a hundred percent
right about that you know what i
actually have another question for you
that scene of you oh god emerging from
the pool yes in the red bikini yeah
looking like a smoke show and a half how
many times did you have to do that wait
question
okay it was the one that you used in the
promo like a thousand times okay so that
was an orange bikini that was my season
sorry only because i did it also in a
red bikini with colton during his season
i don't know if that actually airs
parallels
so it actually stemmed from being in um
singapore or coming out of the water got
it and i was doing a whole like little
halle berry moment and it was like my
thing it was and then
so in the pool i probably only did about
three four times but that's not bad no
it wasn't bad you've got a lot of upper
arm strength oh well thank you yeah but
also at the same time i mean that i like
live for moments like that it was so
iconic and i love how they knew it
because they used that in every single
commercial like a thousand times it was
i mean first of all it's kind of rude
because they didn't tell me that they
were gonna do that
like i thought i was just gonna be part
of like the episode overall next thing
you know it was like my everywhere yeah
you should have gotten paid extra for
that maybe yeah what the heck we have a
bone to pick for how many times i used
it in commercials like it's true it was
so good well thank you you know a lot of
people slide into your dms
you know what
no really like i don't really check them
though but like i would love to go
through your dm's with a fine tooth comb
like honestly that would be kind of fun
i know give me your phone honestly
i won't say people saying that i won't
see people's names no wait this is where
is it you don't have to you know okay
maybe afterwards though
that could be kind of fun i know i can't
believe you don't like i would obsess
over who dm's me i feel like there's
just probably like
famous people in your dms just sitting
yeah but okay unless it's like channing
tatum or like jack carla like i don't
hear it okay so who is your like
celebrity all time
well all time obviously matthew
mcconaughey but like oh interesting
william hemsworth i think he's taken so
like i can't um i think he's taken
i'm so upset at the news i just saw the
picture of her like him and zoe
yesterday and channing tatum yeah is
also unavailable well also
jack harlow yeah but like you would have
to wait in line with a million other
people but this is the thing and this is
the bone i have to pick with this first
of all he's i think he's 23 24 he's
super young yeah i've been into him
since his first album six years ago so
where are we all at
oh you know what where are y'all at you
can cut the lime
wait the light of people waiting outside
to date jack harlow no that's what i'm
trying to get to the front i didn't even
know he was a singer up until like two
weeks ago it's literally to the point
where my friends after first class came
out last week or two weeks whatever
my girlfriend's like random people were
just texting me being like i only know
of this man because you were the person
that introduced me to him that's years
ago driving in your car blasting all of
his songs pick up your phone like i know
sylvia like i know
everything about jack say it to jack say
jack
i'm your girl
that was like so awkward hi my name is
stacia jack i'm available like what are
you doing
i've been married for a hundred years
have you ever well no no well like i
mean i've slided into like a gay man's
dm okay which i'm just like hey queen
what's up like i tried i tried to do
that i don't know i
i'm not entirely sure but like i've said
many times there is a gay man living
inside of me so i feel like i really
relate to the gay men and that's why i'm
i feel very confident dm and gay men see
that's i'm fine with that yeah but like
me as a woman like should i
try
oh um yeah
the thing is you'll never know until you
try and like life is short take risks
stop it she is smiling so hard actually
which means absolutely not i mean i
don't think i ever would but i'm just
saying like
isn't that so cringy like doesn't that
seem like a fan girl it does but i it
really depends on what you're saying
what is the context of a conversation
sliding into a man's dms
right if you're if you're saying like
hey i'm a big fan like that's loser are
you joking no but if you have something
like oh my friend sarah like you know
like if you have common ground yeah you
have to say the perfect thing right for
them to actually pay attention to me
like okay wait she's not creeping me out
right the check mark helps okay
obviously yeah but i would definitely
recommend that you do that
okay well i compile a list yeah just
think about it okay you're making a list
and checking it twice i love that so
we're sending our best to the darby
family but i do think this is the best
for everyone i agree next up lizzo is in
a relationship
she revealed that she's currently dating
someone and she went basically um on
radio andy getting the scoop love radio
andy yeah um so she was spotted out
twice with a mystery man and he was
wearing a mask and a hat both times so
like no one could see who it was we
didn't know if it was someone famous
right and she revealed on radio andy
that she has been seeing someone for a
while
um he's not a celebrity and then andy
asks like what's it like to be so famous
and date someone who's not famous and if
it's weird she said it's not weird if
you have the right person if you have
the right person no not at all it's not
even a factor it should be a mutually
supportive no matter what that it should
be mutually supportive no matter what
that person does um so i love that liz
was in a relationship i love that she's
dating someone not famous because like
she's such a big star like a lot of
celebrities you use dating as like a
means of climbing
yeah yeah and she's just like so famous
that she doesn't need it and she's just
like dating someone who makes her happy
yeah and i love that for her no wonder
she's been like literally glowing and
like the happiest living her best
freaking life and her music is like very
positive exactly like behind the scenes
like she has it going on and she's in a
relationship and nobody else is meddling
into that like it's probably
so refreshing peaceful yeah what are
your thoughts on dating
as someone who's well known by other
people like do you find it makes it more
difficult to date um
to be honest with you i don't yeah i
don't really date very much right it's
just really hard yeah i guess you just
don't know like
people's intentions at times and like i
don't want to be the person to be
constantly on the lookout and like be
hyper vigilant like what are your
intentions right like paranormal seems
like a little weird but also at the same
time i will say like people in new york
are so nice and friendly and i feel like
they also aren't like weird yeah people
in new york are a different breed like
nothing phases them yeah and it's nice
especially for dating yeah and also
you feel like a lot of people are
watching but not everybody's watching
which i love too but do you think when
you do start like diving in more into
the dating scene you're going to
gravitate towards
famous people or non-famous people i
mean
again jack if you're listening
absolutely
but um i'm not opposed yeah i think it
really depends on the situation yeah
like i definitely would not do it like
social climbing or pr stunt right
because that just seems like a freaking
headache and yeah i can't not be
truthful but it has to be fun you know i
mean it could be fun like very
scandalous but like
whatever um
but also dating like a very normal human
also sounds really fun it sounds lovely
yeah and i just imagine lizzo in a
relationship is probably like the best
girlfriend she's so so funny i was just
gonna say she's probably so fun she's so
charismatic she doesn't give a [ __ ] i
wanna know their dates are like i know i
wanna know how lizzy like got to this
place of mental clarity because like
it's it seems so healthy even with all
the faith all of it i i'm so jealous of
people who so clearly are living their
best lives like really everyone says
like i don't care what people think but
like i care um a lot
but actually yes yeah but she's one of
those people you could tell like she
totally talks to talk and walks the walk
and i love to see people who clearly
have just like really good mental health
i mean of course you never know what
people are going through but like yeah
she just seems so positive and like
actually happy no i i agree it's not a
facade it's not like she's like putting
it on from the camera right
she yeah there's you can definitely tell
when it's like genuine it's like almost
tangible also i almost feel like
she's
she's gotten where she is because she's
unapologetically herself and like it's
not because she's
you know stick then amazing like model
body and like this that this that like
people genuinely love her because she's
an insane singer
i love like just like her energy
confidence her energy everything that
she exudes like
like is relatable and so true for that
it's like i feel like that has to be
like a major confidence boost like right
you're right like she got famous being
exactly who she is yeah and she never
had to change like i think a lot of
people will tell you their experience in
the industry it was like they were
always told like cut your hair get a
nose job lose weight exactly and she got
to just like rise to ayla's stardom as
completely authentically herself and
that must just be like the best feeling
in the world she's good as hell i
literally do this
i love liz i thought she was great on
snl also she's amazing her new music
sounds fabulous i saw her perform at
global citizens festival in the city and
she was just
like another level and the flute just
gives me light
it is the most random thing and i just
say i would never put her in a flute
together she was in marching band and
she just looks magical it's magical and
every time she brings out it's like a
combination of funny yeah unbelievably
shocking how talented she is
and when you think about it like singing
dancing in front of
so many people is so tough like your
breath work probably you have to have
like a really good breath and then to
blow a flute
wait that's i never thought about always
thinking like how is she not out of
breath i just stand up for 10 minutes
and i cannot breathe like i'm choking
by the end of the show i'm like i need
to go to the hospital i think does
anybody have a bag what is it what it's
called
i need a brown paper bag
so i always think i'm like that is so
impressive that she can also do all that
and it's so true i never thought about
that it's so true kudos to lizzo kudos
chalizzo literally kill it on all fronts
i'm good on it radio andy for getting
the scoop like we actually all want to
know
um next up i i have any excuse when i
have a new guest on to talk about the
smith family because i'd love to hear
their take on the slap okay so we have
some jada news but i want to hear your
take on the slap first i was so confused
i mean i at first i was like this is a
stunt like i'm just
i actually feel really i feel like will
let me down i know just because like i
grew up with him like he
america's sweetheart freshman i
literally like who didn't binge it every
single night i actually use it to go to
bed yeah so like i really look up to him
like he's always been like such like a
light and a positive figure so like when
that happened i was just like
it actually hurt
it was such a letdown it was such a
letdown and like i hated associating his
name with
every article that was coming out
totally and it doesn't stop especially
because him and jada are very public yes
very open you know red table talk the
entanglement and now jaden smith is
giving thoughts on well a source is
giving thought so we don't know if he
actually thinks this is not actually but
i thought it was interesting just like
getting his perspective on jada like
being so open you know coming to the
table every time there's a fight in the
family like some things can be private
yeah um but a source is is saying jayden
knows that his family's a little
different and how open his mother is
about their personal life and that has
never been easy for him he also goes on
to say um
no sorry this article has a thousand ads
get out of here oh my god so [ __ ]
annoying
so despite this the discomfort um
at this point he's used to having his
personal life on display yeah and even
criticized at times he just wants to
move past the oscars slap
um i guess i never really thought about
like we always know like will and jade
are like kind of messy yeah but i never
thought about the impact that it has on
the kids especially because willow's on
the show but jaden is not so he doesn't
really have control over what's shared
it's interesting to me because like i
can appreciate jada
um
not being such like a refined woman
where she feels like she has to like
pretend like everything's okay and she's
able to talk and talk about real life
stuff so people can actually like
i don't know learn and feel relatable
everyone has [ __ ] absolutely but at the
same time
some things can be private i really feel
that way especially family stuff the one
thing
it's like your kids that you have to
like protect you know what i mean i'm
not saying like i'm sure she's a
phenomenal mom and like
but for me
if that was my situation like i don't
know if i would feel good talking to
like about an entangle with my daughter
right here i'm so sorry to interrupt i
just remembered something that i have to
tell you about what okay okay why do you
know not skinny banana fat yes you know
she uses that gif of you all the time
it's a lot
do you know that it was referenced in
her interview with kim kardashian
yes okay you're lying okay thank you i'm
oh my god okay we for those who don't
know not even out that is a hilarious
instagrammer and she loves to use this
gif of tasha i think it's from your
season yeah where you're saying it's a
lot yeah and anytime like a celebrity's
like being extra she'll always post the
gif it's a lot and it's become like her
thing yeah and kim kardashian was on her
podcast and kim kardashian follows
amanda is her real name yeah and like
loves her content because it's very
kardashian focused and she in the
interview she was like
it's a lot as you like to say
oh
my
god see this is the thing we need to be
friends it's happening the universe is
so crazy i'm sorry it's actually beating
kind of fast i'm sorry to interrupt i
just had to tell you that because i
forget everything wait
okay so this is iconic okay so this is
it's this is my moment it's possible
okay
so kylie um
joking all jokes aside i'm sorry to have
interrupted you back to will and jane i
just wanted you to know that that's
amazing i'm so happy you told me that
because i wouldn't know no i know and i
totally forgot it's like a very nice
it's a very niche what do you think
about that jeff it's so funny that's
because
all i ever say is it's a lot like that
i'm sorry but like it's a lot legit it
is
okay there's a lot of things that have
just been happening
recently it's just it's a lot to
whatever and i also see how like
i think a lot of people are very open at
the beginning of their careers
um but will and jada are like extremely
rich extremely established like
permanent a-listers um they don't have
to like keep telling us everything i
know and it's kind of at least for me
and i think the general consensus on the
internet it's like we're now starting to
get like annoyed with that well cause
it's like it's like just keep yeah it's
just keep stuff to yourself yes you
don't need to know about literally
everything and the entanglement was a
lot it's how do you
i mean like that should be kept what and
after the slap like all this content
that they've posted over the years has
started to resurface just like content
that like rubs you the wrong way
and now it's just like they seem kind of
toxic
but this is the thing is it both or is
it just one who do you think is toxic
i mean i feel like jada just like says a
little too much yeah no it's like it's
almost like you want us to talk [ __ ]
it's like almost like you want to
constantly be the topic of like are you
doing things to
get a reaction like it's i don't know it
just seems odd to me yeah and she's the
one on red table talk and it's her show
and i actually love the the
the theme of red table talk and like the
concept of it i agree and i love like
the three generations sitting and
talking hard conversations um
but i think a lot of times they do over
share that's what i'll say it's funny
though because like usually i feel like
us like we want to know more of course
but like it's funny that we're like it's
a little much because you want to know
why when it's family stuff it gives me a
pain i feel like
one thing that should always be
protected it's kind of like the
kardashians they do a very good job and
they always have each other's back no
matter what no matter what and they'll
blow up and they'll over share exactly
but they always at the end of the day
are protecting one another and the
reason why i think they've had such such
success is because they've remained this
unit yes forever i mean the robs and
china stuff was like a little chaotic
yes but they never tethered from being
like a strong core family and you know
you can't mess with them or like poke
and pry and like
with this it's just like a little too
much i agree it's a lie it's a lot i
think that's gonna be the name of
today's episode it's a lot with tasha
adam
um okay we're gonna keep going into the
fast five that is brought to you by
stamps.com time is money don't waste
either with repeated trips to the post
office with stamps.com you can skip the
trip and focus on how to take your small
business to the next level stamps.com
lets you print official postage right
from your computer and it saves you
money in the process so you spend less
time at the post office and more time at
making your customers happy so for more
than 20 years stamps.com has been an
indispensable resource for over one
million businesses they give you access
to all the post office and ups shipping
services you need right from your
computer and you get discounts you can
cannot find anywhere like 40 off usps
rates and 76 off ups whether you're an
office sending invoices a side hustle
etsy shop or a full-blown warehouse
shipping out orders stamps.com will make
your life easier all you need is a
computer and a standard printer no
special supplies required you're up and
running in minutes printing official
postage for any letter any package
anywhere you want to send stop
overpaying for shipping with stamps.com
sign up with promo code toast for a
special offer that includes a four week
trial free postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
required go to stamps.com click the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code toast all right next up we
kind of say one thing yeah please you're
like a queen like you like do really
well with that thank you so much no look
it's really really good you know it's
keeps the lights on here at the morning
test and you know when jackie's here i
feel very comfortable but with the
co-host you know i feel like um a little
nervous sometimes yeah i get that i get
that because i've done that as well but
like you just did that in one take which
i just want everybody to know that's
really freaking hard that is so nice no
it's really hard are you still hosting
bachelor happy hour podcast no
you're over it yeah gotta go love that
for you but um i feel like you read
books really fast i do actually like
that's also what i got from i talk
really fast what's the last book you
read um and right now we're reading the
seven wives or husbands of evelyn hugo
my favorite everybody else is reading
it's it's so it's really good what part
are you up to i am spoiler alert wait
yeah are we allowed to say it but we
said spoiler alert
cecilia stopped talking to her and so
um we're talking about like basically
evelyn's like i lost her forever right
and this is like where we're trying to
depress yeah and you know that netflix
bought it and making it a movie stop
well cause i feel like it's everywhere
like everyone is talking about it is the
biggest book ever it's so good okay it's
so good i can't wait to finish and you
read it i did read it um okay next up is
something i never thought was like two
people i didn't even think knew each
other okay apparently our friends and
their kids are friends jessica simpson
opened up in an interview that her
daughter maxwell and northwest are bffs
um and that she thinks they're gonna be
a part of the change in this world so
she was doing an interview and she said
one of maxwell's best friends is north
and so watching north she's amazing
she's a great kid and she will be a part
of change in this world her and maxwell
she said eric her husband coached north
in basketball just recently so it's been
really fun because they live in the same
neighborhood so it makes it really easy
for the girls to like hang out and i
never put these together like two rich
queens obviously their kids play in the
same league but i'm i'm obsessed the
next book you should read is jessica
simpson's memoir is it good it is one of
the best celebrity memoirs of all time
it's juicy as [ __ ] oh my god because i
actually really love her love
he was a huge jessica simpson stan
growing up um we have the same birthday
and like that was like i never felt so
special i never felt so special in my
life
do you know who your birthday buddy is
beyonce you're kidding
yes that's like not fair you just
totally want to upped me yeah i'm so
sorry okay that's iconic when's your
birthday september 4th but it's gorgeous
day i know it's
it's it's actually pretty amazing so you
can relate to like feeling better than
your classmates back in the day i mean
yeah yeah i always would be like it's
also beyonce's birthday but like no big
deal that's like
i know it's actually a good one but so
is jessica simpson i know and like i
love her you will love her book me and
jackie have raved about it jackie raved
about it it's really long and for me
like i have such a short attention span
if the book is over like 350 pages
you're like my ass will not read it like
i just won't or i'll stop like halfway
through i couldn't put it down really
unbelievable okay wait i'm gonna read
that and a lot of celebrities talk in
their book about their childhood which
is like the worst part of the celebrity
book just like tell us the juicy stuff
yeah but the way she grew up is insane
like it's just i forget like her dad yes
ashley
like they ran this church in like a
really poor part of town and like just
the craziest stories of how like her mom
helped people in the community it was
really amazing um you'll love the book
okay okay i'm going to read it and then
like john mayer
it's so good we okay okay putting it on
the docket um but her kid is friends
with northwest and i just i would have
never guessed never i guess i never i
forgot like her kid is the same age as
norah right and i always forget like how
rich jessica simpson is from her
clothing line like she doesn't even do
me so true it's like a billion dollar
company jessica simpson clothing
holy mackerel and she just bought it
what a queen no i know it was owned by
kohl's i think yes yes she totally
bought it out she owns a company herself
now oh my gosh i didn't know that she's
a rich queen so of course like her and
the kardashians are just you know
watching soccer together wait but i kind
of need her to come out with like an
album again i know well so how fun would
that be if you buy the ready if you buy
the audiobook okay of her
book the end has a couple
songs of one is one it's really good
okay okay okay i'm listing it tomorrow
my flight tonight she talks about her
journey with music like it was really
toxic because of her dad i could imagine
and there's just a lot there um
and she's just a queen okay so her kids
play with north
i wanna okay you know what i wanna know
what
if they're friends and they're teenagers
like what their texting situation would
be like can you imagine being like those
conversations like oh my god like who
else is their age i need to figure this
out penelope disick is their age okay um
i don't know about what other celebrity
kids but i'm thinking about it's like
when they grow up and like become like
the lindsay lohan parrots hilton i'm
just going clubbing paparazzi
style icons it's gonna be insane it's
going to be insane and like i might be
50 years old but like i will be
interested
100 i'm like that is so cute i can't
wait for that no it's actually gonna be
amazing and we're gonna be able to tell
our kids like you know back in my day
they're my mom's work
our
yeah sure whatever mom they're probably
gonna think that we're like so older
whatever like why are you interested but
like i will be caring about this
absolutely for years to come oh my gosh
i can't even i'm like excited for their
looks i cannot imagine northwest and
maxwell being teenagers i know but like
it looks they'll serve i guess like all
parents feel this way and like i'm not
even north parent but like they really
do grow up so fast no
north was just born i remember the
picture that kids posted of north in the
crib like i remember everything
okay also did you see the article where
um like sandra and channing like their
kids got in a fight at school and they
went to the principal's office together
sandra bullock and yeah yes they got
sent to the principal's office yes they
like something happened they had like an
all like a fight at school and like they
literally called each parent into the
principal's office and like could you
imagine like sitting there like sandra's
like the mom to the kid that your kid's
getting invited with i would literally
the so thirsty i am
i would move to l.a send my kids like
the best school
and tell them to start a fight
with the kid whose parents are most
famous
so then i can get called to the
principal's office and it's just me and
jason mama i literally said the same
thing i'm like i'm i do not condone
fighting because at the same time like
just like you like tap her shoulder a
little bit you know or tell her she's
ugly you know
do whatever it has to take okay do what
you do what do you gotta do what you
gotta do that is so funny i'm telling
you like what if they all go to high
school together wow like see like real
what is it the oc yeah come to life or
like beverly hills house 90210
well i grew up in the remake era okay
well yeah i watched a grimes yes silver
do you remember her name silver and that
was her name silver her name was annie
no annie yeah but the other character
her name is silver and i remember i
wanted to be named silver so bad the
girl with a short haircut and like
really pretty blue eyes i don't remember
oh yes yes yes yes yes her name was
silver yeah
yes and um analyn mccord yes as naomi
which is
such an iconic character and sarah
foster as naomi
yeah
that was such a good show amazing and
meghan markle was in it
no yes so like you wouldn't have
remembered her but when she got you know
famous with harry yeah yeah the scene
she's just a random extra who's giving
someone a [ __ ] in the back of a car
and she like picks her head up and it's
like what and you're in joke no i swear
it's meghan markle oh my god i would
have never oh my gosh okay now i really
need to go watch it the more you know
you watch honey
i'm so happy for north and maxwell
would i think i'm about to become a
full-time babysitter in the northern
california area it's a really good idea
all right final story is a little bit of
a developing story i don't know if you
know that blac chyna and the kardashians
are in court right now
had no idea so blac chyna sued them
they counter sued this is like hundreds
of million dollars she's suing them for
damages they she claims that uh the
kardashians had the tv show rob in china
cancelled and like now she's suing for
damages whatever it's all back and forth
there's been a lot of news but now
people are like quaking because blac
chyna's mom tokyo tony yeah has been
making these like unhinged videos on the
internet and posting them during the
trial like she was outside the courtroom
yesterday talking about the kardashians
are so scared of blac chyna because
they're losing in the courtroom and she
went on instagram live yesterday and she
threatened the judge she said i'm going
to get that judge oh
my gosh and that actually could have
like really bad implications for her in
court so blac chyna's mom tokyo tony may
have taken her displeasure with the
judge a little too far because she's
allegedly threatened him in her
daughter's trial against the kardashians
tokyo went off on the judge while live
streaming tuesday on instagram from just
outside the courthouse where the civil
case is underway she said i'm going to
get that judge she's reacting to the
judge booting her from the courtroom
earlier that day she was asked to leave
and this could be extremely problematic
for tokyo because even an oblique threat
against a judge is taken really
seriously by law enforcement especially
after attacks against judges and their
families have increased measurably over
the last few years she's been super
active on instagram this week going off
on the social media platform on monday
ripping the kardashians over their
appearance um on the first day of the
jury selection so
she said um the family looked dead and
compared chris jenner to the bad guy
from the movie saw oh
she's unhinged like she's really out of
control
she seems
like i hate calling people toxic but
she's toxic no she's the definition of
toxic and like honestly i don't know the
legality i don't know if blac chyna has
a leg to stand on but in the court of
public opinion her mom is making her
look terrible i'm just going to say like
she's basically losing it for her
daughter right
why would you people do not realize
i know they want to like get their
message across on live but like honey
you're live no like you can't take that
back live is a death sentence no it
really is no i think this woman is so
insane
and i can't believe that like for the
next couple of weeks our kardashians are
gonna have to sit in a courtroom with
blac chyna i'm sure they [ __ ] hate
blac chyna how can you
should be so
it just seems like it's just if it's not
one thing it's another i know
what was it before like also it's tyga
too it's tyga it was like having a baby
with rob really out of spite this is so
messy
and there was also a bunch of drama last
week where she was claiming that um she
doesn't get paid enough child support
blah blah and it was on the shade room
actually was really funny so she was
commenting on the shade room and the
shade room made it a post like blac
chyna claims she doesn't get child
support and tyga commented and was like
i have my kids six days a week why would
i pay child support oh [ __ ] and then rob
commented i have my kid every day but
tuesday why would i pay childcare oh my
god so they both like came together were
comparing how much they pay and tyga i
guess pays like a couple thousand
dollars a more more a month towards blac
chyna and he was like making jokes about
how he has to pay more he's like rob
how'd you get off paying slap it was so
crazy so she's just like the definition
of messaging she's messy and i think her
mom and her are just not making her case
in a literal sense saying it like
honestly i feel so bad dream is the
prettiest
child it's and you know what like it's
the kardashians even after all that
china has
they've been through with china they
love that kid oh my god they treat her
so well
and i didn't know that the kid was
living with rob mostly full time i
didn't know that either i just assumed
it was the kid was with china yeah but i
also just feel like there's so many like
kids in the family like
it would be so bad to like exclude her
and like i'm so happy that she's all
totally but the way that she came into
this world was just so crazy that was so
crazy remember when rob posted a picture
of her vagina on instagram oh my jesus
that was just it's been it's been a
freaking roller coaster since day one as
we refer to it as the vagina it was just
the craziest day in pop culture history
and like to this day to this day to this
day nothing crazier has happened oh my
god they were just so messy i'm actually
really looking forward to seeing how
this plays out i don't think that the
kardashians had anything to do with rob
and chyna getting cancelled first of all
because if they didn't want the show to
happen they would have happened first of
all yeah second of all uh robin china
broke up
yeah that's actually so true why would
they continue it on right like you're
not together really messy like we don't
need another jerry springer show i feel
like breaking news oh my god breaking
news thank you lizzy sent it to me oh my
god asap rocky has been arrested at lax
wait what
asap rocky was taken into custody as he
flew into lax this wednesday morning
eyewitnesses at the airport tell tmz
that the rapper flew into la from
barbados on a private jet where he was
met by cops at the terminal and taken
away in handcuffs according to nbc news
the arrest stems from a november 2021
shooting where an alleged victim claimed
that rocky shot them three or four times
grazing the victim's left hand
so he was in barbados because rihanna's
i think wants to give birth in barbados
yeah and she's like close she's at the
point where you can't really travel so
she's staying in barbados and i guess he
had to come back because he was under
arrest and he like surrendered himself
wait this is like really bad and so
stressful for rihanna wait how can this
be happening okay is she about to get
before she feels i don't think she's
there yet because she was able to fly
down to barbados and they say you can't
fly past seven months so i think she
might still have a good time
but still regardless wait this is really
juicy okay my heart is happy right now i
know that's the thing morning to the
bottom of this you never know what's
gonna happen
wow i know this suddenly is like the
segment you need to be listening to
every single morning
which by the way my mom listened
yesterday and she was like did you know
that it's theo's birthday it is oh well
thank you so much for saying that it is
theo's birthday today everyone he turned
five if you want to go wish him happy
birthday on his instagram pups with no
job check it out um i'm really just
wishing the best for rihanna i'm really
nervous for her now she doesn't need
that kind of stress i was just gonna say
that it's very bad for the baby to be
stressful so we need her to be keeping
her peace also because now she's like in
barbados which is so far away i know so
it's like you feel helpless
oh gosh well breaking news we'll keep
you updated on that developing story um
before we let you go tasha i need you
for our deer toaster segment yes so we
do it every wednesday if you guys ever
want to write in it's dear toasters
gmail.com we've got some unique
submissions today and we just try our
best to give advice you know that we
would give our own sister you know
and it's brought to you by better help
people don't always realize that the
physical symptoms of
stress like headaches teeth grinding and
even digestive issues are indicators of
stress and let's not forget about doom
scrolling not sleeping enough sleeping
too much and under eating and overeating
are all symptoms that you might be going
through something and better help is
here to let you know it is so easy to
find someone to talk to
stress shows up in all kinds of ways in
a world that's telling you to do more
sleep less and grind all the time this
is your reminder to take care of
yourself do less and maybe try some
therapy better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in person therapy
so you can give it a try and see if
online therapy helps lower your stress
if you don't find someone that you like
you can switch it really easily with
better help finding a therapist who
works for you it's called therapist
shopping it's very common and it's
really easy to do on better help and the
morning toast listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
toast that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
toast all right tasha our first
submission comes from a girl
who needs some help
hey girls i'm 24 years old and my
roommate and close friend who's 23 we
both work at the same restaurant as
servers there's a 60 year old man who's
a regular that comes in every day and
has been banned before banned before for
drinking too much being too loud and
being creepy towards and um and touching
the servers inappropriately this is the
man who is now my roommate's new
boyfriend i've told her several times
that i don't feel comfortable with him
having
her having him over at our apartment and
regardless of whether i'm home or not i
still don't feel comfortable she doesn't
think it's fair that he can't come over
here and doesn't respect the fact that
i'm uncomfortable he also has his own
place that they can go to that's less
than 10 minutes away we also have a
third friend slash roommate who lives
with us but she doesn't work at the same
restaurant i just feel weird that he
would want to come over and hang around
three young girls in their 20s he has
two daughters who are older than us and
i'm not judging my friend for who she
chooses to date but i just personally am
not comfortable with him being around so
what i'm wondering is if i'm an [ __ ]
for telling my friend that i don't want
her boyfriend to come to our apartment
even if i'm not home it feels like it's
pushing a personal boundary since i have
to serve him at work all the time since
he comes in every day the reason i'm
torn on what to do is because it's still
her apartment as much as it is mine and
i do have my boyfriend who's the same
age as me sleepover sometimes what do i
do
wow
i mean that's a lot
that's a lot
it's weird first of all 100 and i know
you're not judging your friend but like
i would
okay wait so i'm it's just to clarify
she knows about all of these things yes
then yeah then i would she works at the
restaurant too what is like the point
what are you doing honestly like i don't
think you're out of bounds for asking
him not to come over
especially when you're home where it
does get a little dicey is like
you asking her not to have her boyfriend
over when you're not home like what
what's what's the danger there yeah i
would agree with that if i'm home i
don't feel comfortable and like as my
roommate and as another person that like
pays rent right this
place i would like for you to respect
that boundary and if he's 60 years old
he probably has his own house like why
does he want to hang out with girls
three girls who live together that's
what she's saying that's so creepy and
weird
but also at the same time i feel like if
you express this feeling and she doesn't
reciprocate or understand i think it's
your time to kind of move out i know
the thing is like you're the one who's
uncomfortable so i do think that means
you're the one who has to leave exactly
not her because you're the one with the
problem and moving you know i don't know
where you live but it's impossible to
move in new york right now it's so tough
we get it
i mean i mean you can be a [ __ ] i was
just gonna say i'm just gonna say wait
what would you what are you doing that
situation then i mean if that was me
like i'm out like my house is my safe
space i'm like a real homebody some
people use their house as a place to
sleep and they're out all the time not
me [ __ ] like i'm home all the time i
eat home i eat at home i live at home i
host at home everything is home so for
me this is a huge deal breaker and like
i would spare no expense i'd be really
uncomfortable how do you sleep i would
be i would be so comfortable i couldn't
do it same and i would do anything to
then find myself a new place where i
feel safe but again like it's it's
expensive um i think you can try to
be really stern with her
and maybe try asking her to not have him
over when you're home yes and see if
that makes you feel better yes i agree
and then try to try to see if you can
spend more time at his place i don't
understand why they wouldn't that's so
odd to me it's so odd is that not a red
flag obviously and your friend that's
what i'm saying like your friend seems
like her priorities are [ __ ] up i'm
really sorry that you're in that
situation because there's a difference
between dating someone older i think a
lot of young girls do that like they
date someone older for fun and right
they buy them stuff it's fun right
but when
when this man has like a history of
being creepy it's just not it's not the
vibe it's your turn to get out it's your
turn to go yeah um or maybe you start
dating someone and start spending a lot
of time at their house like start couch
surfing yeah where does your boyfriend
live because she said she had a
boyfriend where's your boyfriend with
your boyfriend now this is what this is
the exact step we forgot about that this
is the exact step you need with him be
like babe i'm really not feeling
comfortable at home i need to move in
with you and the next thing you know
you're married can i say tonight can i
say tonight and then you know do you
want to just move in yeah like i forgot
we're helping you out okay wait i forgot
do you love this man
that's no more details the boyfriend is
your answer
i agree with that thank you for bringing
that up yeah this next one is psychotic
okay oh god hey claude and tasha
my boyfriend theo and i have been
together for five years we've been
living together for two years and we've
been discussing next step next steps and
marriage and i couldn't be more excited
theo and his two female gay co-workers
who are dating each other went out to
lunch out of the office this past week
i'm friendly with the couple and i've
hung out with them casually a handful of
times but they aren't mine or theos like
best friends or anything
at lunch they asked theo how comfortable
he would be by giving them a sperm
donation in the near future so they
where it would be able to conceive a
child
theo told them that i probably wouldn't
have any issues with it and that he
would love to do that for them when theo
told me i shared with him that i was not
comfortable with that situation
whatsoever i don't want you to have a
child in the world that we do not care
for and i don't feel a weird need to
co-parent his offspring that's out in
the world
if his sperm is going to produce a child
i want it in my uterus and in my home i
also was hurt considering how big of a
question that is and that this couple
didn't include me in the discussion
considering that they know me theo told
me that he would not theo told me that
he would love to provide his coworkers
what they biologically cannot do for
themselves and that my stance was very
selfish i can see myself as a mom in the
future but i also cannot see myself
as a mom theo and i could thrive in any
scenario but our recent discussions
about our future do not have children in
them i feel like most women just know
that they want to be a mom and i
honestly haven't ever felt that feeling
but i may in some time for context theo
and i are both approaching 30 the female
gay couple is in their mid-30s and
they've been dating for about a year
they aren't married ladies what do i do
should i tell the couple i'm not
comfortable with it and kindly um
and kindly not to ask theo knowing that
he is comfortable with it or just give a
time and hope that they find another
donor any advice is appreciated this is
so much to understand hold on a second i
need to like just catch my breath yeah
because like i actually can't breathe
after i was like holding my breath like
the entire time there's so many layers
versus your theo not asking you and just
saying yes is a like it's a red flag
that's rude it's such a big decision
it's such a red flag to like not even
consider your feelings absolutely
especially because like he's not single
right he's dating you and the couple
asking theo without the girl present
absolutely it's also a strategic move on
their part because of course because
they know that he's gonna say right like
oh my god because i don't think a man
really thinks about it no as anything
other than like fluid he's donating
whereas a girl really sees it as a
biological connection i agree so i mean
this is beyond bizarre it really is and
you have every right to be mad at
everyone involved for not including you
and then just making a decision that
does affect you without you
but where do we go from here that is i'm
not entirely sure okay wait hold on one
second they're engaged or they're just
dating just dating
for a year
okay i definitely think it would be an
entirely different situation if they
were engaged the gay couple no oh sorry
the gay people and her gay couple are
engaged theo and her are not yeah but if
theo and her were engaged it would be
totally different but also at the same
time damn this is hard i know
because i agree like
you do want to like i i love that theo
wants to be like super sweet and like
help them out and i love the sentiment
but also at the same time i feel like
it's really putting him and his
relationship in a really awkward
predicament
and like
i get it like but why do you want his
specifically like that's a little
strange to me like there are services
for this right and you know what like i
i think that if you're a couple who
needs a donation whatever your
circumstances are it's actually very
easy and i think affordable to get sperm
they're sperm banks um i think where it
gets really pricey and complicated is
when you buy eggs
so for a lesbian couple i think that and
a sperm donor i think you can really
customize like you can find out this
person's family history medical history
looks athletic
yeah
so i feel like it would just be way
easier to go to a sperm and then you
don't want to have the whole complicated
like what if you and theo you know get
into a fight like with a sperm donor
it's totally anonymous
jeez okay
what do we tell her i mean honestly i if
it were me i would tell him that i'm
that i don't want him in a situation me
too i tell them and i think honestly him
not telling you and then him being mad
at you and calling you selfish like huge
theo red flag well yeah that's uh is he
gonna make other like really big life
decisions without you like
that's kind of strange yeah no that's
really [ __ ] up so basically i think
you need to actually like
evaluate your relationship if it's
something that you actually see long
term that you're going to get engaged to
and like you want to be with this man
and mary have his well maybe have his
babies then i think you should
definitely vocalize if it's something
that like you know what you're kind of
on the fence and like you've been kind
of feeling like maybe this is my guy
maybe not this might be that could also
come into play and like this might be
your sign to be like you know what maybe
this isn't the relationship for me
because he's not considering me and he's
really like which is so stupid his
answer should have been i'm honored you
asked me i have to talk to my girlfriend
100
and the fact that he totally dismissed
your feelings and just you in general
like
is making me mad no i know i'm kind of
fired up i don't i don't like this at
all and i think like you know this might
have been a blessing in disguise because
people show like their true colors and
i'm not encouraging you to break up with
your boyfriend or anything but like i
don't know it's worth thinking about hey
after like this is you know you kind of
think about that big time and just kind
of the way he no a lot of it is
bothering me yeah i agree i agree i
think you need to evaluate if this is a
relationship you want to pursue and if
it is like you need to have a major
conversation with this man and don't let
him just blow up blow off your feelings
like you have completely validated you
can't get mad at you like oh i'm trying
to help my friend i understand that but
at the same time like do you see a
future with me because like i should be
considered in that
as well and the fact that you didn't is
huge whoa yeah heavy topics here with
deer toasters wow i've got one more for
you t-shirt okay
um anyways i have a guy friend in high
school who was my best friend we were
always very flirty with each other very
touchy-feely but we never dated he got
married right when we graduated and he
has since had four kids we're both only
28. we lost touch after high school and
we only really keep up on facebook i met
my boyfriend almost four years ago and
we are totally endgame he's the love of
my life well three days ago the my old
male best friend messaged me on facebook
and told me he's getting divorced then
he asked me if i had any single friends
and how to use dating apps i was up
front with my boyfriend i shared with
him all the messages my boyfriend was
not worried we have a pretty normal
trusting relationship the weird part is
now the guy friend is asking to hang out
with us i understand he's newly single
and never lived a single life i mean
he's never even been to a concert oh my
gosh but i think him asking us to hang
out is just so weird am i overreacting
do i tell him no or do i invite him to
our next outing any help is appreciated
my boyfriend trusts me i just don't want
to disrespect him and also how do i know
that the friend isn't trying to
infiltrate my relationship
um i feel like you're being kind of
paranoid yeah it seems nice like i feel
like you're pathetic listen i feel like
as a person that has actually been
divorced and like it's a very lonely
time like you kind of latch on to people
that
i don't know like are close to you but
also you kind of want to like just get
out there and feel like a different vibe
so maybe he's just like looking for some
type of friendship and it's nice that he
thought of you and you think about it so
he's 28 he got married right after
graduation he has four kids he probably
doesn't have a lot of friends exactly
and that's why the first memory that
comes to mind is you and for you it
feels weird but for him it's like oh my
old friend katie yeah he probably still
thinks like really fond of like that
relationship that you guys once had yeah
so that yeah but at the same time i
wouldn't hang out with him one-on-one no
of course i would definitely invite him
like as a group a barbecue i don't think
that's weird i don't think it's weird
either and i think you're right like the
i mean i've never been divorced but i
imagine it's extremely isolating it is
especially when you have friends as a
couple and they get like split up and
you know you thought you were really
friendly with someone but they go with
the other people kind of lose like all
people right around so i think it's
sweet that he's reaching out and i don't
think you have anything to be worried
about if your boyfriend seems cool i
thought you were gonna say your
boyfriend's being like weird and jealous
yeah yeah yeah yeah but he's being cool
so just try to hit on you right that's
how i thought the situation was me too
but you're never gonna regret you know
being nice and offering you know an
invitation to a barbecue fill it out
once and if it feels uncomfortable then
like you can also just like okay like
whatever it's making me sad that he's
reaching out to you yeah he hasn't made
like a ton of really good friends since
high school
yeah i think he's just like he's like
trying to like find himself again
truthfully and like you kind of revert
back to like what you
you were used to yeah
it's sweet that's you i think you're
being a little paranoid me too i think
it seems harmless so i would respond and
okay you know what just be kind i i
think that's the message here yeah
invite them over invite them over but
like in a group setting yeah
um those were dear toasters again if you
ever want to write in it's dear toasters
gmail.com tasha you are an absolute
queen for being here giving us
everything beauty grace she's miss
united states um everyone can keep up
with tasha on instagram at tasha
t-a-y-s-h-i-a anything else you want to
promote um
no just okay how do i speak right now
i'm happy you're just living your best
life yeah i love you thank you so much
for being here i really appreciate it
you guys thank you so much for listening
to the morning toast the millennial
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have radio catbox all the
places so if you listen to podcasts find
out some morning children leaving five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are have an amazing day
we're back tomorrow with remy bader bye
bye
that was
you